we have today jet travel we have today
the fact that almost anyone can have
children we have the situation today
because of prosperity and because of the
Nestle revolution because of of
international travel that there's mixing
of the genes which means that the gross
evolution of the entire species itself
has probably slowed down but does that
mean that evolution has stopped
no people still prefer other people who
are healthy this means that we are
evolving toward becoming healthier and
healthier people there's a reason why we
are attracted to certain people of the
opposite sex according to evolutionary
psychology what we want is healthy mates
beauty for example according to one
theory is a way in which we have of
judging the health of another person the
theory says for example that if you are
at a bar on Friday night and you want to
quote pick up somebody rapidly you can't
do a blood test you can't do a physical
examination to find out how healthy that
person is so you need markers according
to evolutionary psychology the markers
are for estrogen and testosterone shown
in the body by beauty and physical
health for example estrogen has estrogen
markers large eyes small chin and thick
lips same thing with testosterone
testosterone makes large necks and
strong jaws and lower voice that also
means the person is fit the person is
healthy these are markers that we use so
the point I'm raising is that evolution
on a one-to-one basis is constantly
taking place because we constantly
prefer people who have a better immune
system people who are physically fit
masquerading as what we call handsome
pretty